pour yourself another glass of liquor we
got a new episode of Silo and with it a
bunch of new theories Clues and
Mysteries as always I've left links to
all the topics I'll be covering in the
description below and don't worry there
won't be any spoilers I haven't read the
book so everything here is done through
sleuthing now prepare to go outside
let's get into it hot off the heels of
Juliet discovering George's citizen
record in the event of former Sheriff
holston's apartment Juliet hopes that
these files May provide some Clues as to
who murdered George but as Juliet will
later tell Martha there wasn't any
information in these files that she
didn't already know so why then would
Holston go through all the trouble of
hiding these files if there wasn't
anything of value in them well there are
still some interesting bits of
information here it was Deputy marnes
who conducted the interview into
George's possession of relics
specifically the watch which George said
was legal but if you look closely there
is another familiar name on these five
files of a character we saw in episode
1. Gloria Hildebrandt she was also
interviewed and we know that her
character believed there was more to The
Silo than meets the eye even insinuating
that the reason Allison wasn't able to
get pregnant was that the people in
charge didn't want her to in episode 1
Allison visits Gloria for a second time
hoping to learn more about the truth but
we never see their full conversation so
it's a safe bet that there is much more
to Gloria in her relationship with
Allison that may prove useful to Juliet
this episode gives us greater insight
into Mars's murder introducing us to a
character named Douglas Trumbull
Trumbull is a member of the judicial
with aspirations of shadowing Sims and
under orders from him undertakes the
assassination of Mars after Mars refused
to replace Juliet with newcomer Paul
Billings what I'm curious about is who
Sims is taking orders from is it judge
Meadows who I believe is this woman
although she's never mentioned by name
or is it someone or something far more
secretive later in the episode we see
Trumbull visit Sims outside the
janitorial closet sims's father was a
janitor yet had the power to transfer
his Bully's entire family it's implied
that the janitor job was merely a front
for a far more important one if Sims
wanted to know what his father did he
would need to Shadow him and agree to
never tell anyone what was on the other
side of that door whatever is behind
that door would change sims's life
forever his job and those who work
behind that door quote do the most
important work of The Silo work that
keeps ten thousand people alive what I'm
curious about is whether this is
something judge Meadows knows about or
if Sims is working for someone else
entirely also is this just me or are
these film canisters in the background I
mean they could just be pots and pans
but it's a little too hard to see Sims
and Trumbull had planned to frame a man
by the name of Patrick Kennedy for the
murder of Mars by placing rat poison and
Mars's drawing of Mayor Ruth in his
apartment but little did they know that
due to a clerical error Patrick had
moved out of that apartment shortly
after his wife's death this was how
Juliet was able to catch Trumbull
returning to the scene of the crime Sims
knowing he has to cover his tracks kills
Trumbull and trumbull's death is deemed
as suicide since Trumbull was now wanted
for almost killing Juliet but when
Juliet tells judge Meadows she can look
into why this guy would want Mars dead
Meadow says not to waste any more
resources on it almost as if she knows
the truth so the question then becomes
did Judge Meadows task Sims with killing
Barnes who in turn ordered Trumbull to
do it unfortunately this Grand planned
to make Juliet look like a fool
backfires and she ends up solving the
case and getting on interim mayor
Bernard's good side it's a pretty
strange change in demeanor which Juliet
picks up on why would a guy who hated
her for stealing tape a few episodes ago
now be so enthusiastic to work with her
and just a reminder if you like these
types of videos and want more please be
sure to let like And subscribe it really
helps the channel out what I find rather
troubling was Bernard's craftiness not
only does he want to craft a story about
Ruth and Mars being in love remember he
doesn't know that they actually were but
he wants to distract the citizens with a
race to the top foot race and a
forgiveness holiday and do we really
believe him that he doesn't want this
job and will be glad it's over in a few
months he sure seems to like the perks
of indulging in Ruth's liquor we also
get a little more insight into why Sandy
has been so cold towards Juliet not only
does she think Juliet only took this job
to find out who killed her lover but she
also thinks Juliet may have something to
do with holston's death Mars told her
that something happened between the two
and that's why Holston went out to clean
so Sandy's pissed a woman with no
knowledge on The Pact is now in charge
and may have been responsible for the
death of her beloved co-worker I'm
curious if she'll be back since at the
end of the episode she requests a
reassignment we also get our first look
inside the offices of judicial both of
Judge Meadows and Sims there isn't
anything too crazy that I wanted to
point out besides this vault-like door
behind sims's desk it just makes me
wonder what kind of sensitive
information is in there and if it has
any connection to this stuff beyond the
Janitor's Closet Paul Billings mentions
a group called The friends of The Silo a
group Juliet calls listeners from what I
can tell these are individuals who are
kind of like de facto spies working for
judicial they provide reports to them
but none of what they say is admissible
in court the friends of The Silo think
that our poisoner is a gambler by the
name of Ralph Melby but we know it's not
him so the friends of The Silo are not
to be trusted that is if they even exist
at all since this info came from Sims in
judicial who is trying to make Juliet
look incompetent it can't be trusted now
this isn't the first time characters
have expressed concerns over being
watched in this episode Sandy tells
Juliet that she feels she's being
watched but isn't sure by who or how and
in episode 1 Gloria turns on the lost it
in her apartment so that those listening
in won't be able to hear her
conversation this implies that these
spies may have listening devices All
Around The Silo one of the more
interesting new developments is Lucas
and his tracking of the Stars oddly
enough neither Lucas Juliet or Martha
refer to them as stars rather lights
implying that they never learned basic
astronomy in school which I found rather
odd why wouldn't the powers that be not
want them to know about stars Lucas has
been tracking a particular constellation
that looks like a w this is Cassiopeia a
constellation only visible in the
northern hemisphere so if what we're
seeing here is real remember that it
could be a recorded screen it would
imply The Silo is located north of the
equator now if there are any Avid
astronomers out there and you can pick
up more details on this screen I'd love
for your input in the comments below
heading back to the down deep Juliet
catches up with Martha who's uncovered
this microchip inside the camcorder this
Segways into her two big mysteries about
the pack number one it stipulates no
mechanization of how people go up and
down the silo that's why you don't see
any pulley systems or elevators with
this mechanization interfere with
something it's just a huge red flag the
second mystery ties into the camcorder
no magnification is allowed Beyond a
certain power and Martha theorizes with
wiring this camcorder has being so small
its power will be quite strong with the
previous scene being about the Stars
could this device be used to get a
better look at them or perhaps figure
out something about the screen we also
get a small bit of information about
Juliet's mother creating a more powerful
magnifying glass that judicial destroyed
last episode we saw how her mother let
the recovery of Jacob leading me to
believe she's some sort of doctor or
scientist last episode we also saw
Martha had the camcorder hooked up to a
computer and I'm still curious if she
found anything else on there similar to
how Allison and George hooked up the
hard drive to a computer tutor to
uncover a ton of secret files the
episode ends with Juliet retrieving the
duck Pez dispenser left to her by George
in episode 2. in order for Julia to
continue looking into George's murder
she'll need to open an investigation
that allows her to look into it without
raising suspicion and the way she's
gonna do that is with the right bait
with the implication being that this Pez
dispenser is the bait I'm really curious
what she intends to do with it with my
only real theory that since it's a relic
she may plant it on someone to open a
new investigation now we get into that
part of the video where we look at the
trailers to see if we can glean any new
information keep in mind that I'll only
be going over the images that deal with
a new clue or mystery that appeared in
this episode check out this glasses and
magnifying glass Contraption I'm curious
if this is a flashback of Juliet's
mother building that powerful magnifying
glass the one destroyed by judicial or
perhaps this is Martha recreating it but
I doubt it based on the hair it looks
like Gloria is back and in some sort of
Hospital a few shots later we see some
soldiers approaching a long-term care
facility could they be after Gloria
after all she was what she called a
Wanderer someone who questioned what was
really going on in The Silo we also got
this shot of Juliet hiding behind a desk
in a hospital-like setting but we can't
be certain whether or not this is the
long-term care center with Juliet's
father also being a doctor I wonder if
he'll come into play here's that shot of
Juliet connecting the hard drive to a
computer now I've been looking at all
the deaths of everyone in the show and
haven't quite found a match on whose
computer this is but if you think you
have an idea let me know in the comments
below speaking of comments let me know
what you thought about this week's
episode and your theories on what will
happen next thanks for watching please
make sure to like And subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember
foreign